joining us now with reaction is former
homicide detective and fox news
contributor ted williams and the co-host
of the buck sexton and clay travis show
box sexton who is also a former member
of the nypd's intelligence division
gentlemen and ted let me start with you
uh it's good to see you uh you know
there's clearly there's there's still
mourning and there's still sadness and
grieving and there's now some rage as we
get more information because we've got
to know this information in order to
know what to do and what goes wrong and
what we can fix
tell me your thoughts now with what
we're seeing and how this is unfolding
for us so far
well time as you've already said we do
have to get this information and we have
to get it right and we need to know the
truth of what took place
we were told yesterday in a press
conference by the governor
and uh the head of the texas rangers and
the lieutenant governor and other
officials there that the first person to
come in contact with this killer was the
security officer at that back door
the back door we now learn was unlocked
we also now know that there was no
security officer and we also know that
by the time this guy got into that
school into that room we there was
gunshots and then
this guy was in there for one hour and
i'd like you to think about this and i'd
like our audience to think about this
you had
four 19 children that had been shot and
you had 17 or more that had been injured
and those kids were in there for one
hour
with this killer and those who are now
living i am sure tammy that they are
scored and perhaps scored for life and
what should have happened what should
have happened is what happened 23 years
ago we learned a lesson at columbine and
that is to go in the law enforcement and
neutralize the person right away that
did not happen here they gave us false
information yesterday and as a result of
that unfortunately some kids may have
been saved or we don't know that but
there could have been some people well
we know uh buck just from this report
from the wall street journal if it's
accurate a a mom
goes into the the
arena gets into the building in the
midst of all of this accesses the
building finds her children
removes them from the building again
this is for her report wall street
journal reporting what she's told them
and rescued her own children a mom
did this
this is also when we think about the
governor
perhaps they were given the wrong
information that it looks like the local
police report they were reporting
nobody seems to have the the correct
information at all what do you think
with your background in intelligence and
what's required here i know it's a small
town no one's going to forgive
themselves for the rest of their lives
we don't want to pile on here but we we
must know the nature of what missteps
were taken
that's absolutely right because it's
essential that we do what's necessary
going forward to try to uh prevent and
certainly mitigate to the greatest
degree possible a situation like this
and i just say that the timeline of what
we know right now occurred from a law
enforcement uh perspective response uh
is just unacceptable it's too long it's
too slow so i understand they're saying
there are additional details that need
to come out but the fact of the matter
is just based upon what has already been
confirmed they had an active shooter who
was still shooting over the course of
that hour of the weight while he was
inside
um and and the prior point was already
made that there may have been children
who were hit who are bleeding out speed
is absolutely of the essence and that
you could have had as many as around 100
law enforcement officers on the scene
setting up a cordon and preventing
parents from going in and then a parent
actually manages to get in and save her
own children just goes to show you this
was a breakdown and people are going to
be studying this in the law enforcement
community for a long time i think about
just how commanding control on the scene
what tactics techniques and techniques
and procedures need to change here what
was the breakdown how did this occur
because
nobody would ever look at this study the
situation from a pure law enforcement
perspective and say this is the way this
is the playbook this is how we're
supposed to respond in this circumstance
i know it's a small town they don't have
a lot of resources but they had a lot of
armed personnel on the scene and one 18
year old with a rifle uh ted you know we
saw some of this also when it came to
the parkland shooting uh clearly that
played out where we knew about a school
resource officer hiding a different
police department coming in to finally
move in that environment that what
happens on the ground can be shocking
these are people who are trained to do
something you have to wonder it's like
are police affected by the rhetoric
we've been hearing for years about law
enforcement uh is is this a dynamic that
where there needs to be massive national
retraining about how to respond to a
violent incident but it seems strange
that when even especially children are
involved at schools in this dynamic
parkland and now here that things were
not done when they could have been done
what do you think ted is is at the core
of this reticence and this
problem
well you know i it listen uh and i'm in
defense of the police there's always a
great deal of confusion when you have
these kinds of unfortunate events but
there were kids in there these law
enforcement officers knew that there
were kids in there and these kids were
should have been
immediately or there should have been an
attempt to rescue them even if you would
have to try to breach the door they
should have had some kind of way to try
to get into that room and they should
have got in right away you could not
wait an hour just think about it young
kids in there
terribly upset because they waited one
hour before going in there to try to
rescue them it's absolutely shocking
buck i'll give you the last word here
because again every day is going to
bring new information and we know
everyone involved is is shocked and
struggling with how they acted and what
happened uh where do you think we go
from from here
well i'm familiar with how bureaucracies
work including law enforcement
bureaucracies and i think that some of
the
uh the reported information that turned
out to be incorrect we're going to see
that there's a bit of a scrambling going
on among some of the authorities
involved here to come up with what the
narrative will be
that doesn't end up sounding like a lot
of cops stood around with screaming
parents saying save our children inside
there's a maniac murdering them i think
that's honestly the the takeaway here is
just going to be that they don't really
want to get the information out there
quickly because the information of the
response here is is not good uh the law
enforcement or sponsor with the
exception of the border patrol tactical
team that went in there and ended the
threat
look thank you gentlemen i mean this
comes down to no matter what kind of a
plan you might have no matter how much
money or you know what the strategies
are it comes down to
the humanity the humans involved and
being able to act on that thank you so
much for joining me tonight hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else